it was my first year as an atmospheric
science professor at Texas Tech
University we had just moved to Lubbock
Texas which had recently been named the
most second-most conservative city in
the entire United States a colleague
asked me to guess teach his
undergraduate geology class I said sure
but when I showed up the lecture hall
was cavernous and dark as I tracked the
history of the carbon cycle through
geologic time to present-day most of the
students were slumped over dozing or
looking at their phones I ended my talk
with a hopeful request for any questions
and one hand shot up right away I looked
at courage and he stood up and a loud
voice he said you're a Democrat aren't
you no I said I'm Canadian
that was my baptism by fire into what
has now become a sad fact of life here
in the United States and increasingly
across Canada as well the fact that the
number one predictor of whether we agree
that climate is changing humans are
responsible and the impacts are
increasingly serious and even dangerous
has nothing to do with how much we know
about science or even how smart we are
but simply where we fall on the
political spectrum does the thermometer
give us a different answer depending on
if we're liberal or conservative of
course not but if that thermometer tells
us that the planet is warming that
humans are responsible and that to fix
this thing we have to wean ourselves off
fossil fuels as soon as possible well
some people would rather cut off their
arm than give the government any further
excuse to disrupt their comfortable
lives and tell them what to do but
saying yes it's a real problem but I
don't want to fix it that makes us the
bad guy and nobody wants to be the bad
guy so instead we use arguments like
it's just a natural cycle it's the Sun
or my favorite those climate scientists
are just in it for the money I get that
at least once a week but these are just
sciency sounding smoke screens that are
designed to hide the real reason for our
objections which have nothing to do with
the science and everything to do with
our ideology and our identity so when we
turn on the TV these days it seems like
pundit X is saying it's cold outside
where's global warming now and
politician Y is saying for every
scientist who says this thing is real I
can find one who says it isn't so it's
no surprise that sometimes we feel like
everybody is saying these myths but when
we look at the data and the Yale program
on climate communication has done public
opinion polling across the country now
for a number of years the data shows
that actually 70% of people in the
United States agree the climate is
changing and 70% also agreed that
will harm plants and animals--and it
will harm future generations but then
when we dig down a bit deeper the rubber
starts to hit the road only about 60% of
people think that it will affect people
in the United States only 40% of people
think it will affect us personally and
then when you ask people do you ever
talk about this 2/3 of people in the
entire United States say never and even
worse when you say do you hear the media
talk about this over three-quarters of
people say no so it's a vicious cycle
the planet warms heat waves get stronger
heavy precipitation gets more frequent
hurricanes get more intense scientists
release yet another doom filled report
politicians push back even more strongly
repeating the same sciency sounding
myths what can we do to break this
vicious cycle the number one thing we
can do is the exact thing that we're not
doing talk about it but you might say
I'm not a scientist how am I supposed to
talk about radiative forcing or cloud
parametrizations and climate models we
don't need to be talking about more
science we've been talking about the
science for over 150 years did you know
that it's been 150 years or more since
the 1850s when climate scientists first
discovered that digging up and burning
coal and gas and oil is producing heat
trapping gases that is wrapping an extra
blanket around the planet that's how
long we've known it's been 50 years the
scientists first formally warned a US
president of the dangers of a changing
climate and that president was lyndon b
johnson and what's more the social
science has taught us that if people
have built their identity on rejecting a
certain set of facts then arguing over
those facts is a personal attack it
causes them to dig in deeper and it digs
a trench rather than building a bridge
so if we aren't supposed to talk
more science if you don't need to talk
about more science than what should we
be talking about the most important
thing to do is instead of starting up
with your head with all the data and
facts in our head to start from the
heart to start by talking about why it
matters to us to begin with genuinely
shared values are we both parents do we
live in the same community do we enjoy
the same outdoor activities hiking
biking fishing even honey do we care
about the economy or national security
for me one of the most foundational ways
I found to connect with people is
through my faith as a Christian I
believe that God created this incredible
planet that we live on and gave us
responsibility over every living thing
on it and I furthermore believe that we
are to care for and love the least
fortunate among us those who are already
suffering the impacts of poverty hunger
disease and more if you don't know what
the values are that someone has have a
conversation get to know them figure out
what makes them tick and then once we
have all we have to do is connect the
dots between the values they already
have and why they would care about a
change in climate
I truly believe after thousands of
conversations that I've had over the
past decade and more that just about
every single person in the world already
has the values they need to care about a
changing climate they just haven't
connected the dots and that's what we
can do through our conversation with
them the only reason why I care about a
change in climate is because of who I
already am I'm a mother so I care about
the future of my child I live in West
Texas where water is already scarce and
climate change is impacting the
availability of that water I'm a
Christian I care about a changing
climate because it is as the military
calls it a threat multiplier it takes
those issues like poverty and hunger and
disease and lack of access to clean
water and even political crises that
lead to refugee crises it takes all of
these issues and it exacerbates them it
makes them worse I'm not a Rotarian
but when I gave my first talk at a
Rotary Club I walked in and they had
this giant banner that had the four way
test on it is it the truth absolutely is
it fair heck no that's why I care most
about climate change because it is
absolutely unfair those have contributed
the least to the problem are bearing the
brunt of the impacts it went on to ask
would it be beneficial to all would have
been build good well well to fix it
certainly what
so I took my talk and I reorganized it
into the four-way test and then I gave
it to this group of conservative
businesspeople in West Texas and I will
never forget at the end a local bank
owner came out to me with the most
bemused look on his face and he said you
know I wasn't sure about this whole
global warming thing but it passed the
four way test
these values though they have to be
genuine I was giving a talk at a
Christian college a number of years ago
and after my talk a fellow scientist
came up and he said I need some help
I've been really trying hard to get my
foot in the door with our local churches
but I can't seem to get any traction I
want to talk to them about why climate
change matters so I said well the best
thing to do is to start with the
denomination that you're part of because
you share the most values with those
people what type of church do you attend
oh I don't attend any church I'm an
atheist he said so I said well in that
case starting with a faith community is
probably not the best idea let's talk
about what you do enjoy doing what you
are involved in and we were able to
identify a community group that he was
part of that he could start with the
bottom line is we don't have to be a
liberal Treehugger to care about a
changing climate all we have to be is a
human living on this planet because no
matter where we live climate change is
already affecting us today if we live
along the coasts in many places we're
already seeing sunny day flooding if we
live in the Western North America we're
seeing much greater area being burned by
wildfires if we live in many coastal
locations from the Gulf of Mexico to the
South Pacific we are seeing stronger
hurricanes typhoons and cyclones powered
by a warming ocean if we live in Texas
or if we live in Syria we're seeing
climate change supersize our droughts
making them more frequent and more
severe wherever we live were already
being affected by a changing climate so
you might say ok that's good we can talk
impacts we can scare the pants off
people because this thing is serious and
it is believe me I'm a scientist I know
but fear is not what is going to
motivate us for the long terms the same
change we need to fix this thing fear is
designed to help us run away from the
bear or just run faster than the person
beside us
what we need to fix this thing is
rational hope yes we absolutely do need
to recognize what's at stake of course
we do but we need a vision of a better
future a future with abundant energy
with a stable economy with resources
available to all where our lives are not
worse but better than they are today
there are solutions and that's why the
second important thing that we have to
talk about is solutions practical viable
accessible attractive solutions like
what well there's no silver bullet as
they say but there's plenty of silver
buckshot there's simple solutions that
save us money and reduce our carbon
footprint at the same time yes
lightbulbs I love my plug-in car I'd
like some solar shingles but imagine if
every home came with a switch beside the
front door that when you left the house
you could turn off everything except
your fridge and maybe the DVR lifestyle
choices eating local eating lower down
the food chain and reducing food waste
which at the global scale is one of the
most important things that we can do to
fix this problem I'm a climate scientist
so the irony of traveling around to talk
to people about a changing climate is
not lost on me the biggest part of my
personal carbon footprint is my travel
and that's why I carefully collect my
invitations I usually don't go anywhere
unless I have a critical mass of
invitations in one place anywhere from
three to four to sometimes even as many
as 10 or 15 talks in a given place so I
can minimize the impact of my carbon
footprint as much as possible and I've
transitioned nearly three-quarters of
the talks I give to video often people
will say well we've never done that
before but I say well let's give it a
try I think it could work
most of all though we need to talk about
what's already happening today around
the world and what could happen in the
future now I live in Texas and Texas has
the highest carbon emissions of any
state in the United States you might say
well what can you talk about in Texas
the answer is a lot did you know that in
Texas
there's over twenty five thousand jobs
in the wind energy industry we are
almost up to twenty percent of our
electricity from clean renewable sources
most of that wind those solar is growing
quickly the largest army base in the
United States Fort Hood is of course in
Texas and they've been powered by wind
and solar energy now because it's saving
taxpayers over 150 million dollars yes
what about those who don't have the
resources that we have in sub-saharan
Africa there are hundreds of millions of
people who don't have access to any type
of energy except kerosene and it's very
expensive around the entire world the
fastest growing type of new energy today
is solar and they have plenty of solar
so social impact investors nonprofits
even corporations are going in and using
innovative new micro-financing schemes
like pay-as-you-go solar so that people
can buy the power they need an increment
sometimes even on their cell phone one
company Azuri has distributed tens of
thousands of units across 11 countries
from Rwanda to Uganda they estimate that
they've powered over 30 million hours of
electricity in over ten million hours of
cell phone charging what about the giant
growing economies of China and India
well climate impacts might seem a little
further down the road but air quality
impacts our rate here today and they
know that clean energy is essential to
powering their future so China is
investing hundreds of billions of
dollars in clean energy they're flooding
coal mines and they're putting floating
solar panels on the surface they also
have a panda shaped solar
[Applause]
yes they're still burning coal but
they've shut down all the coal plants
around Beijing and in India they're
looking to replace a quarter of a
billion incandescent light bulbs with
LEDs which will save them seven billion
dollars in energy costs they're
investing in green jobs and they're
looking to decarbonize their entire
vehicle fleet India may be the first
country to industrialize without relying
primarily on fossil fuels the world is
changing but it just isn't changing fast
enough to us and we picture this problem
as a giant boulder sitting at the bottom
of the hill with only a few hands on it
trying to roll it up the hill but in
reality that Boulder is already at the
top of the hill and it's got hundreds of
millions of hands maybe even billions on
it pushing it down it just isn't going
fast enough so how do we speed up that
giant boulder so we can fix climate
change in time you guessed it the number
one way is by talking about it the
bottom line is this climate change is
affecting you and me right here right
now in the places where we live but by
working together we can fix it sure it's
a daunting problem nobody knows that
more than us climate scientists but we
can't give in to despair we have to go
out and actively look for the hope that
we need that will inspire us to act and
that hope begins with the conversation
today thank you
[Applause]